so today's topic we want to look at love
and attachment so I got a little clip I
want to show you guys because it kind of
exemplifies how I think a lot of people
tend to love and attach themselves in
relationships with their exes as well
now it's time for some of our viewers to
ask some questions and talk back so
here's the first question we have hey
Steve my name is Amber and I'm from
Arizona and I watch you everyday on
three TV Arizona family
okay that's your first promise anybody
who's watching Steve Harvey every day is
getting a daily dose of stupid I just
realized this is like xx Steve Harvey
video we were asked to so my best friend
recently got married but I've always had
a crush on one of her ex boyfriends and
I'm just wondering if it's okay for me
to date him now oh I understand how this
question comes from logical thinking
she's gone now she's taken but I'm gonna
give you the emotional standpoint that's
gonna be a hell no we just take a second
to appreciate the fact that all women
like we're not just emotional creatures
we're capable logic as this grid says
like but let me give you the emotional
side but my feelings don't emotional
standpoint that's gonna be a hell no
okay okay
monique is there you okay cuz watching
with ever mine no you're my friend
that's a hell no the trust is officially
going to be altered I would be like I'm
sorry when did this attraction start
exactly when we were dating that's when
it started okay I've got a big problem
what you just said listen ladies if you
feel like your [ __ ] like this just just
do it just do it you saying that when
did this attraction start when we were
dating hey listen if I'm dating a girl I
hope other people are attracted to her
too right
please let's not protect the men you go
for aren't attractive to many other
women you see qualities in that man that
makes them very sexy
you don't think other women are gonna
see that I got there's a reason why
women love showing pictures of the
boyfriend they think is cute to their
friends because they want their friends
to be like oh he is cute I agree so you
being attracted to them all the women
are gonna be attracted what woman would
want a man that's unattractive to
everyone else do you think the wife of
Jason Momoa gets mad cuz people think
he's her husband he's not done getting
mad I judge their be mad all Baker's
girl every woman is on that and you
don't think her friends think he's hot
so what do you think it's weird that
they would be attracted to but there's a
lot of minato
like that what a lot of men are like
that too a lot of yeah look at my wife
like that
don't don't be talking to my wife you
can't yo your wife I'm not I don't have
any intentions for your wife but your
wife is attractive but you know what we
define that s we defined that as being
too possessive yeah so that kind of
behavior from a man is seen as wack I
don't know why these women get claps
from all this what group of guys would
be just clapping cuz I'm good dude said
that exactly I think what you did there
to personally use me as a friend my
trust would just be altered I would
never be able she acts out
my husband you know not all promises
discussion is it's always centered in my
feelings but this is two other people
who are trying to find their own sense
of happiness and for you for you to love
these people and to not want them for
themselves is extremely selfish that's
why when people talk about love
especially women they don't realize how
possessive they sound when they talk
about it and so me it bothers me on this
conversations happy that so many people
are clapping because I'm like I don't
think guys understand the concept of
loving people at all because love is
selfless
meaning even if it's to your own
detriment you have to be happy for
people who are finding each other and at
the end of day it's not really to your
detriment except for your own ego
because you feel like you have ownership
over this person you don't want your
friend to get with them but a total
stranger can [ __ ] them but if you want
your friend to be happy and they were
gonna both make each other happy why
wouldn't you give your blessing you have
the potential to create a happy family
but you're so in your ego that you're
like nah you don't get to do that
because I [ __ ] him first
how stupid do you have to be to think
that that kind of emotional manipulation
is healthy that was my ex no [ __ ] is
the [ __ ] that you don't no
longer go out with okay that goes male
and female it's someone you no longer
have a relationship with it's not your
ex my possession my this mind it's not
it's not like that
you know Oh nobody when you're with them
you don't owe nobody when you're not
with them make your own list right
worked with a lot of women that are
struggling to find love and if she's
your friend and she happens to see it
and a dude that you no longer want know
don't hate on your girlfriend and that
is called the voice of reason give me
two seconds you should join in on this
[ __ ] I want to clap or two now there you
go now you done let's go
[Music]
now for a man it's hard for a man
because a man causes this oh man I can't
go behind my boy but just think about
for example Steve you are you know you
work in entertainment you're celebrity
so your circle tends to be a lot of
other famous people and I find that
people that work in the same industries
and they have a small circle of people
around them so a lot of people meet
somebody at work they meet somebody
through friendships so I think that you
can't just rule it out because it's
unfair I think it's unfair for us to be
that kind of friend and put that kind of
pressure I like somebody who is just
trying to find love I'm not hurt you
just trying to find love you you see how
she's talking about the other person's
feelings you see how she's being
empathetic and being putting the other
friend first everyone else around this
panels like well my trust I would feel
terrible it would make me angry it's a
hell no for me what she is talking about
is the well-being of others and that is
a very distinct difference
I always analyze how people measure
their love by how much they talk about
themselves versus the other person and I
think that's a real measurement of what
it means to devote yourself to somebody
to actually be caring and I find this
kind of behavior the other people are
exhibiting extremely toxic because it
said centered an ego is centered itself
and it's not centered and listening to
what other people want that's the
definition of being unemployed Diane
Diane Valentine beautiful I love what
you're saying oh girl live and I can
actually love when she says it she
really means it with a lot of empathy
and care and I think that's beautiful
just trying to find love I feel like
seven billion people in the world go
friend you want there's other people in
your now that I've reached all them
people you know yo oh what are you gonna
do I'm gonna serve the seeds of India to
myself a girl like that who the [ __ ] you
are
[Laughter]
I think it's unfortunate because if they
actually listen to what the end said she
said most people meet people within
their circle most people meet people
through friends and so for you to say
there's seven million people well most
people are not meeting people because
there's a wide expansive human beings
because approaching total strangers is
actually quite scary and frightening for
most people and so if you look at the
statistics of how most relations are
happened most of them actually happen at
the workplace and through friends so
your argument is stupid but again you're
not here for the logic you're here for
the emotions people who love to talk
about their emotions actually really
showcase how little they understand
about their emotions because guess what
emotions are fleeting you're gonna feel
all types of stuff in life but you need
your mind to be right in order to sift
through it understand what's healthy and
what you need to let go and a lot of
people are holding onto emotions that
are actually very negative like pride
and ego and selfishness and they don't
even recognize because they masqueraded
as love as attachment and you think it's
healthy no [ __ ] that shit's toxic and
you are now poisoning everyone else
around you because you're not willing to
use your brain to understand what's
going on within yourself a lot of these
people that preach my
- that they preach understanding and
emotion and intelligence they're super
shallow man you know what's funny is
that women always left to talk to me
about like a men need to get more in
touch with their emotions when I talk to
women about what they're feeling
oftentimes they don't understand [ __ ]
they just allow themselves to feel
everything and they allow themselves to
talk about what they feel but they don't
actually understand how this I really
that's pretty much it for today's video
I want people to be more mindful in
regards to how they love and how they
think about their levels of attachment
to people because most of it is just
possessiveness and ego and I just want
you guys to keep that in mind yeah a guy
with a deep voice was like is it love
what is love so leave your comments
subscribe that's how you support the
brand okay
like comment subscribe
[Music]